I'm very pleased to be here to receive
the Board of Governors honorary Academy
Award it's it's a great wonderful
recognition of the work I've been doing
for 50 years what's kept me going is
that it's fun and an adventure
constantly working also keeps me off the
street or at least on the streets that I
like while making the movies is is
physically and intellectually demanding
its surrender I felt any strain I'm
lucky I've found work that I like and
that I continue to be obsessed with this
this compulsion has always been
understood by my wife Zipporah and my
son's David and Eric I'm grateful and
very appreciative for their constant
support they recognized long ago that
I'm a New England Jewish Puritan and let
me go my errant ways I and I'm also I'm
also very pleased that my my
grandchildren Tess and Ben and Charlie
are here tonight to to help me celebrate
I want to to thank Karen karna Czech who
has run my production company Zipporah
films for 35 years
and whose unfailing good cheer and sound
advice has made it possible to wander
around and make movies I also want to
express my thanks and appreciation to
John Davey the terrific cameraman with
whom I work since 1979 I'm glad that
both John and Karen are here tonight I
also want to acknowledge the
contribution of the late William brain
the cameraman who worked with me on many
earlier films as well and also want to
thank that many others who helped in the
production of the movies
Irwin young the president of do art
films one of the independent filmmakers
best friends provided deferment deals
which made many of my early films
possible I'm grateful to PBS for its
support for all of my films the film's
couldn't have made without couldn't have
not have been made about the constant
support of the Ford Foundation and
frequent grants from the MacArthur
Pershing Square and left foundations
itvs and the sundance documentary fund
additional funding has sometimes been
provided by my singing and selling
pencils outside the Neiman Marcus
department stores making a movie is
always an adventure I usually know
nothing about the subject before I start
and I know there are those that feel I
know nothing about it when it's finished
I
I never start with the point of view
about the subject or a thesis that I
want to prove I also don't do any
research in advance of the shooting
I usually don't know in advance what's
going to be shot what I'm going to
stumble across in any day or any moment
of any day the editing is an effort to
impose order on the chaos of the rushes
through the creation of a fictional form
that provides meaning to the film the
goal is to make a film that is close to
closer to a visual novel than a
journalist account a journalistic
account this process involves sitting in
the editing room for 8 to 10 months
getting fed intravenously until the film
is found each film was also an
opportunity an opportunity to learn
something about a new subject I've been
involved in a 50-year course in adult
education where I'm the alleged adult
who studies a new subject every year the
variety and complexity of the human
behavior observed in making one of the
films and cue literally all of the
film's is staggering and I think is it
it's important to document kindness
civility and generosity of spirit as as
it is to show cruelty banality and
indifference
there are always a lot of laughs and I'm
not the first to observe that so much of
human behavior my own and others is when
seen from a detached point of view funny
for example when I was working on the
film that became near death a film about
dying patients there were several
occasions when we shot in the hospital
morgue on the last day of shooting I
went around thanking the various staff
we've been helpful among them was a man
responsible for the morgue I caught up
with him in the hospital cafeteria and
thanked him for his help we shook hands
warmly and he said see you soon thank
you and see you soon